direct avec nous david poulin les
conseiller municipal d'opposition
ambarès et lada des fondateurs du groupe
et gilet jaune constructif bonjour
monsieur couleurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france à leur
sécurité globale gilet jaune force jaune
y voyez vous une ou plusieurs
mobilisations est ce qu'on y est à cette
convergence des luttes
au delà de la convergence des luttes on
est tout simplement en train d'assister
à une explosion sociale dans notre pays
qui a débuté il ya plusieurs années
parce que la situation sociale dans
notre pays n'est plus tenable
il ya trop de chômage il y a trop de
pauvreté il ya des inégalités qui
explosent et surtout il ya plus d'espoir
y a plus d'espoir actuellement aussi
pour les entreprises les petites
entreprises les commerçants les artisans
qui voit bien que cette crise va
accélérer justement toute cette
explosion sociale
il ya un ras-le-bol général et en face
il ya un gouvernement qui ne répond que
par la répression
la diabolisation et qu'ils ne proposent
pas de solutions concrètes à moyen long
terme et de vision alors on vient de le
voir avec à notre reporter la
manifestation vient de partir l'instant
de paris vous attendez à quoi pour la
manifestation d'aujourd'hui
alors nous sommes très inquiet parce que
la manifestation nous nous sommes plutôt
sur des actions de lobbying ou par
exemple les péages gratuits parce que ce
sont des actions qui sont populaires
pour pouvoir permettre faire comprendre
aux gens que nous devons être tous
rassemblés vers la même cause le
problème des manifestations c'est qu'on
va encore assister à des casses et des
casses contre des personnes qui n'ont
absolument rien fait qui ne sont pas
responsables qui s'appelle des commerces
alors même que ceux qui sont
responsables de tous ceux là n'ont rien
finalement moi je vois pas de
dégradation de permanences d'élus ou des
choses comme ça donc là c'est pour ça
que les manifestations sont productives
dans le sens où elles font passer un
message mais contre-productive dans le
sens où elles vont amener une certaine
casse est une nouvelle fois on va
revenir dans ces épisodes et un prêt les
autres où on aura d'un côté des
manifestants et l'autre côté de la
police et c'est regrettable parce que
pendant ce temps là on ne parle pas du
fond du problème c'est à dire le déclin
de la france
l'explosion de la pauvreté des
inégalités et surtout le manque d'espoir
et une cinquième république et taboo
dessous la france était en état
prérévolutionnaire vous n'allez donc
tuohy aux manifestations mais vous
et solidarité pas du mouvement pourquoi
parce que vos revendications de départ
sont les mêmes on peut pas se
désolidariser d'un mouvement qui
appellent à plus de justice dans le pays
c'est incongru en revanche on s'aperçoit
que ce mouvement malheureusement le
mouvement que nous avons porté a été
diabolisé et il a été infiltré par des
casseurs qui ont un autre objectif qui
est celui de vouloir faire une
révolution dans ce pays là pour changer
le monde pour différentes raisons qui
n'a rien à voir avec plus de justice
sociale et fiscale en ce pays mais ce
que je remarque c'est que les français
sont très en colère actuellement très
très en colère et commence petit à petit
à justifier la violence et c'est ça qui
est très dangereux c'est pour ça que la
stratégie de répression et de
diabolisation atteint ses limites
le gouvernement est obligé d'acheter la
police mais à un moment il va falloir
avant une vision stratégique pour ce
prix là et permettre à la france de
sortir de ce déclin les autres pays
arrive pourquoi ne sommes nous pas
capables de le faire
alors cette manifestation précisément
c'est entre autres un pour dénoncer à la
loi sécurité globale quelle est votre
position là dessus
l'exécutive doit-il à réécrire ce projet
de loi ou l'abandonner définitivement la
liberté d'expression est un droit
fondamental
des milliers des milliers de gens sont
morts à travers l'histoire les jeunes
aujourd'hui parfois l'oubli des gens
sont morts pour qu'on puisse être libre
pour pourront plus avoir des droits
bien évidemment qu'il ya des
problématiques il ya des problématiques
bien évidemment dans les banlieues ou
ailleurs parce que des policiers se font
agresser il faut pas croire que le
policier vilain et méchant ce n'est pas
vrai en revanche il ya des libertés et
je ne crois pas qu'en renonçant aux
libertés on sera progresser la situation
au contraire on est en train d'amener à
créer des lois pour faire taire les gens
et ça va créer plus de tension et ça
sera encore plus dangereux pour nos
institutions
au contraire je pense que la seule
solution d'entreprise aujourd'hui c'est
de créer un gouvernement d'union
nationale est passée par les voix
référendaire notamment sur des lois
sociales fiscales économiques comme
l'âge de la retraite comme le temps de
travail comme comme d'autres loi qui
permettrait justement de lutter contre
l'injustice dans notre pays et c'est ça
qu'il faut faire parce que les
politiques sont complètement discrédités
on le voit bien lors des élections
municipales le gouvernement a avancé ces
élections là les a maintenus le 28 juin
tout simplement pour faire plaisir à
edouard philippe
pour lui
un strapontin donc il a galvaudé tout
une démocratie et on s'aperçoit que
plupart des mères sont pas bien élu et
ne représente plus grand chose
les tensions se démultiplie dans les
villes en loi dans des villes par
exemple comme la mienne où il ya des
grèves du personnel contre son propre
mère ou le maire est complètement
disqualifié parce qu'il est élu avec
très peu de voix donc on voit bien que
nos institutions sont à bout de souffle
et la seule chance de s'en sortir c'est
de passer par le référendum avec vote
obligatoire et on prend des décisions et
on tranche et à ce moment là on avance
tous ensemble dans un seul but et on
arrête d'avoir des élus de droit divin
il décide pour les autres alors qu'ils
sont perchés et déconnecté david poulin
remercie d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur la tête vous êtes conseiller
municipal d'opposition à ambarès et
lagrave et fondateur président md gilet
jaune constructif merci à vous